ich habe aus fragmenten horror video
gesagt wenn in neugebauten leid schafft
kommt 999 geschafft deswegen hier play
wie das ist ein rätsel horror spiel bei
dem james kommen wieder die hochgeladen
habe waren ja mehr so wichtige spieler
also sobald die länder die nicht
vorstellbar machen darf nicht mehr zum
browsergame was wir sehen
man denkt okay dass sie gerade noch aber
will freunde ich habe das mal in der
grundschule früher gespielt und ich habe
mir so die hosen gekackt der
mitmenschliche sind nämlich abstoßen
hier vorne lag und hier um die ecke und
hier vorne um die ecke und dann hier
weitermachen
irgendwann kommt ein paar sekunden
später
vergeht
heute machen wir das erbe der wilden
hier viel laufen hier vorne lang laufen
hier um die ecke lockt ich weiß dass
gleich irgendwas kommt laufen hier um
die ecke hier um die ecke hier und hier
auf der anderen seite lang hier unten
lang bisher die relativ gut aus freunde
apa
oh mein gott oh mein gott freundes
weder durch den bürgern deinen kopf oder
übrigen leute wenn ihr nie zuvor game
haben wollt ob meine fanal dann schreibt
in die kommentare und schafft 95.000
like dann mache ich demnächst neue
pokerspiel ganz einfach nicht so ernst
nehmen musst du einfach ein bisschen
rumlaufen kann so locker flockig machen
leicht gegen welche tolle musik im
hintergrund packen das ganze noch gar
nicht so schwer als ich probiert einfach
mal hier forderung hier um die kurve ich
habe an freunde jetzt wird kritisch was
man jetzt machen muss es eigentlich ganz
nah mit dem kopf an den screen ran und
dann kommt man sonst immer besser
ja hübsch bist du
ich weiß nicht was
passiert wenn ich auch hier drauf
gewartet nämlich nicht wenn ich auch
bittet website clique dann wie mir schon
die website wird
einfach nur andere games ich würde der
raw datei gerade bei sechs minuten bis
es kein langes video bisher ich hätte
nicht gedacht dass das jetzt schon
vorbei ist
ich bin mit meinem leben ich habe ja
auch der website gerade noch ein
weiteres spiel gefunden
das heißt die automaten mails also wir
sehen dass wir jetzt schon eingeblendet
deswegen probiere ich jetzt einfach mal
hier noch irgendwas zu reiten ich klicke
jetzt noch einmal of play und wir sehen
schon navigate mir klicken wieder auf
play und wir müssen jetzt quasi
irgendwie diesem punkt auch das muss
jetzt mit den pfeiltasten machen also
hier vorne auf das rote ziel drauf ist
sind wir hier im nächsten hier vorne
lang hier um die kurve hier um die kurve
ich weiß nicht ob die brauchen sie
herkommen weil es von dem gleichen typen
die decke ist übrigens mein beschützer
vor allem samstags geht ihr vorne lang
gehe um die kurve und jetzt hier einfach
nur noch in der produzieren jetzt wird's
kritisch freunde da oben kommt wieder
irgendwas ihr ganz leicht rom um hier
oben ganz leicht rum
ich bin wieder hier angekommen stellte
hier nach oben gehe hier um die kurve um
hier oben um hier noch einen
ok ich dachte ich bin schon wieder
gestorben alter freunde das ist gerade
echt ist also jetzt hier vor gelang hier
noch ein höher hier um die kurve um
jetzt komm ich kann mir nicht geben
ich kann mir das nicht jeden ohne spaß
ich eine krise
das war der familie meine damen und
herren ich hoffe es hat euch gefallen
wie ich mich mal wieder zum affen
gemacht habe typische gespielt von wegen
ich kaufe spielt für 30 euro und team
hinter dem dinge entwickeln sondern das
war einfach ein stumpfes rätsel wurde
war die gesagt leute 95.000 like dann
wäre ich in nächster zeit mal irgendwann
helfer oder irgendwie sowas spielen
können aber auch gerne andere horror
spiele in die kommentare schreiben und
jetzt
probiodrug wartet ihr video da solltet
ihr von mir
ihr könnt jetzt hier meinen kanal
abonnieren oder hier in meinem shop
checken jetzt findet jetzt für andere
video nun könnt ihr auf die glocke
klicken dann willkommen die
benachrichtigungen
[Musik]